uh how uh Omar is the the back story of
this film is a very interesting one uh
we don't have a lot of uh American
movies with uh three-time Academy Award
winners based on Argentinian plays yeah
probably the first this might be the
first yes yes well this was written
originally for uh for a theater by ocar
Martinez and adopted uh for the screen
by my son Demian romai uh who did a
wonderful adaptation of it and um
and this is a film now
uh so uh and I feel like I've been
pronouncing your name wrong romai is how
we'd say your last name Spanish well I
speak a little Spanish so I should do
better
um so uh do you work often uh with your
son I know you get the answer to this
but I mean this that's pretty wonderful
to have a producer directing and your
son wrote it also adapted it and they
directed it uh he directed it too yeah
it is a wonderful opportunity to um
to I mean just to work with your son is
always wonderful uh there are always uh
challenges
in any Father's son relationship or
mother daughter relationship
um
it is it is good to have the challenge
rather than having him or her apart and
not being to to enjoy or or learn from
from each other through experience I
wish there was somebody here I could
talk to about mother-daughter
relationships so
so it's impossible uh knowing your
history Diane to watch this film and not
uh think about and imagine how your
relationship with uh with Laura during
your daughter influenced you as you
played this part it had to yeah well of
course it did in many ways
um I'm very fortunate to have a great
daughter who's also a great human being
I'm very blessed by God and she and I
have worked together several times and I
love working with her and I loved this
wonderful cast Mary Stuart Masterson
played my daughter
and Sam robarts played my son and Andrew
McCarthy played the ex-husband all
magical actors and a young girl played
the granddaughter but I had worked
previously with Mary's daddy in New York
I had worked with uh he directed me in
Bob dinero 40 years ago Off Broadway and
I had worked with Andrew in a TV series
with Bruce Davidson and I had worked
with Sam Spas as great Jason robarts
twice
so when this script came up and I read
it
Damien wrote the last third of the film
he added that to the two plays maybe
you'd like to talk about how the play
yeah the play ends very differently yeah
well the play originally was there were
scenes in which uh the Victoria
character was talking to the audience
and explaining what was going on on car
live with a with a with a family and
then there were these
scenes in which especially the hospital
scene which is a long scene
two or three scenes in the hospital four
things in the hospital then at the end
uh Victoria comes to a stage and talks
to the audience and explains what
happened with the mother what happened
uh with with her daughter but
uh the whole third Act is it was created
by Damien the value of what he added and
what got Diane to to do it or the fact
that we have a situation here that most
uh parents and children have between
them which is when when is the father
going to say I'm sorry for the mistakes
I've done and most of the parents I
would say 90 95 percent of parents don't
have that opportunity in life to do it
with a with a son or the daughter so
this is this uh this opportunity that
they play or the the movie does is that
it shows that how important how
Transcendent is the fact that when when
a father or a mother
says I'm sorry for whatever
uh uh the son or the daughter had in her
her mind or his mind about uh the the
things that went wrong on their
relationship and that reconciliation
that's what that's what Drew you well
also what drew me to the film is that
like uh Spielberg's fableman our film
which is touching people a great deal
people are calling up and talking about
it is that there's no violence in this
film there's no rape there's no murder
there's no blood there's no car crash a
plane crash it's about people in the old
days Gregory Peck and and Glenda Jackson
Emma Thompson they made a lot of movies
like this but lately there's so much
violence in so many films and I love
this people picture about our problems
as human beings the unresolved part of
the past which is not over which stays
with us and haunts Us in the present and
affects our future so that's what I like
to as an actor to show my job whether
you're Saint a sinner is to show the
Human family in all of its aspects so
that we understand ourselves and each
other a little bit better and easier for
to solve the problems today that we're
facing are in our country and as artists
today I'm concerned about the future
artists did you think about having a
couple of helicopters Collide in the
movie because I think I think that would
have really helped you know I sensed
um so you know there's
I imagine that that as the folks here
tonight and other people who see the
film certainly of uh my generation and
even a little bit younger yeah they're
going to have this subtext going on as
they watch the movie I mean you're Diane
Ladd and you're you're you know the
relationship you have with your daughter
is known and it's it's you know it's
lovely to see especially among people
who've succeeded that there's a real
intense closeness
um and then so you have that and then
you have this other thing of like
oh my God that's Barry Stewart Masterson
and Andrew McCarthy right and they look
at that they did get married right and
in my imagination of course I was like
they must have done three or four movies
together but it turns out it's just one
right but they were like circling each
other throughout the 1980s and and there
is a connection there you know when they
are together in the screen you you know
they they know each other well and they
we feel like we know their history right
right yeah so so I think work for the
audience that that that they enjoy the
movies that they made before together
but also uh for the ones that that
didn't saw those movies the issue that
you see the connection immediately as
soon as they are together in the in the
screen yeah Heaven Help Us was the one
movie they made together I really was
sure they were in three or four together
and I think Mary does some of her finest
work in this film it was her father Pete
Masterson that I worked with years ago
and I think all the actors really met
the challenges head-on that they faced
in the characterization
um another reason that I wanted to do
this film is is to me culture is very
important I just feel there's a saying
that any country who loses its culture
history has proven you lose the country
and I just feel we're in a time right
now where we really need to promote
culture and we need to promote
independent filmmaking where people for
less money have more time literally to
do the work they want to do by the way
my daughter Laura during and I have
written a book called honey baby mine
and it's about talking to each other
it's about communicating it's as much
for Fathers and Sons it is for mothers
and daughters it'll be out Mother's Day
but honey baby mine is in essence
what made me really want to do this film
because I had almost died four years ago
and um taking walks of Dr Tolar I'd be
dead in six months from being sprayed by
poison chemicals tin poison pesticide
chemicals and I didn't die instead I did
two movies a TV series and wrote a book
but when this prescription came to me I
was so pleased at the communication and
the problems between people
so many kids never get to their parents
lie to them they don't tell the truth
because they want to be loved and adored
so you don't tell your kid everything
and then the parents lie and then the
kids lie because they want to be loved
and adored and then when the parents die
it's like why didn't I talk to Dad about
that why didn't I ask my mother that
it's too late
so this picture
you see two people because again she had
a stroke and almost died that you break
through does it take that kind of thing
yes sometimes it does to make us be so
honest and be so vulnerable so I felt
all of that really was in this beautiful
script and I was privileged to be
allowed to do this film can I ask you
were there things that when you had your
experience four years ago were there
things that you ended up saying to Laura
that that you hadn't said to her I get
the feeling you guys say a lot yeah the
fact that she because we she got me a
place near the beach and we started
walking every day to help make my lungs
stronger and we started because she
thought I was going to die she told me
everything because I thought I was going
to die I told her everything so she
started recording it so we took the
recordings the agent said you've got a
book there and we thought oh God but
they had five publishing houses fight
for it so yeah we do we we do talk a lot
very honestly do you and your son do you
you know you've made movies in Argentina
you've been very successful in Spain
right as well
the some of the telenovelas that I
produced were sold all over the world so
mostly
the the country where I see them the
biggest success other than Argentina was
Italy and and
you know what's your this is a different
Beast yeah and I might be is it is it uh
I mean is it worth pursuing here is it
yes I I came to study uh film in the US
in in Los Angeles in 1983 and uh in
1987 after graduation I decided to go
back to Argentina because I thought I I
would not be able to produce anything uh
in the US so I went to Argentina to
produce novelas for for like five six
eight years after that and
um then my son when when he gets time
for him to go to to college he decided
decided to come back to LA and study at
USC uh then finish his master's degree
on screenwriting and um so I we moved to
to Miami uh open television station
local television station for the Cuban
population in Miami
and uh and when that process finished
and Damian started to to do his own
movies I started to help him out
and we produced four together but he has
produced and directed almost 30 in the
last six or seven years but most of the
movies that he has done were for cable
companies for Lifetime in Hallmark that
kind of thing and I always uh as as
Diane was saying uh you want you want
your son to get to his potential and I
thought okay you can make perfect living
with uh with movies by to cable but you
you are you are never going to to see
your movies on a theater so this book
was the opportunity uh that um I I
thought was uh if if I if I don't give
to him that opportunity who is going to
give him that opportunity well you know
you uh you two seem like the uh the
perfect people to make a movie about
parents and their children you know
Cheyenne Ladd Omar romay thank you uh to
both of you guys thank you guys for
coming out we appreciate it uh please uh
thank you if you like the film and I
know you did please tell your friends
thank you very much